>> Jon: HEY, EVERYBODY!
WELCOME BACK TO THE SHOW!
I'M SO EXCITED.
YOU KNOW, FROM TIME TO TIME WE
LIKE TO GET AN INTERNATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE ON CURRENT EVENTS.
MAINLY TO CONFIRM THAT WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
INTERNATIONAL EVENTS.
SO WE'RE HAPPY TO WELCOME BACK
TO THE PROGRAM OUR SENIOR
INTERNATIONAL CORRESPONDENT FROM
SOUTH AFRICA.
TREVOR NOAH IS HERE!
TREVOR!
NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU. THANK YOU, JON.
>> Jon: THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
>> YEAH, OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE ALL
STILL REELING FROM THE TERRIBLE
EVENTS OF JANUARY 7.
>> Jon: OH, RIGHT, NO,
THAT'S -- THE "CHARLIE HEBDO"
MASSACRE, PARIS. THAT WAS --
>> OH WELL THAT, TOO, BUT I WAS
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT THE BAGA
AND DORON BAGA MASSACRES IN
NIGERIA.
>> Jon: YES.
BAGA AND DORON BAGA.
ARE THOSE NIGERIAN SATIRICAL
MAGAZINES? I DON'T --
>> NO, THEY'RE TOWNS, JON.
WELL, THEY WERE TOWNS.
BOKO HARAM DESTROYED THEM AND
KILLED THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
>> Jon: YES!
BOKO HARAM.
I'VE HEARD OF THEM.
HASHTAG BRING BACK OUR GIRLS.
YES?
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
WELL, HASHTAG THEY DIDN'T.
IN FACT, SINCE THEN, BOKO HARAM
HAS CAPTURED AN AREA THE SIZE OF
SLOVAKIA.
THAT'S TWO SLOVENIAS.
THAT'S NINE MILLION AMERICAN
FOOTBALL FIELDS.
>> Jon: HOLY ( BLEEP )!
THAT'S A LOT OF AREA.
I DID NOT REALIZE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, AND YOU'RE NOT
THE ONLY ONE, JON.
NOT A SINGLE HEAD OF STATE WENT
TO NIGERIA AFTER THE
JANUARY ATTACKS, NOT EVEN OBAMA,
AND HE'S AFRICAN.
>> Jon: WELL, WELL, WELL
-- HE'S NOT -- AFRICAN AMERICAN.
HE WAS NOT BORN IN AFRICA.
BORN IN HAWAII.
>> OH, YEAH, RIGHT.
YEAH.
( LAUGHTER )
I GOT YOU.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT. WELL, IF IT
MAKES YOU FEEL BETTER,
OBAMA DIDN'T GO TO
PARIS, EITHER.
>> YEAH, BUT AT LEAST YOU COULD
HAVE SENT US JAMES TAYLOR.
WHAT?
AFRICA DOESN'T GET A FRIEND?
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: SETTLE FOR PAUL
SIMON?
>> OH, OKAY BUT ONLY IF HE
PROMISES NOT TO STEAL OUR MUSIC.
HASHTAG BRING BACK OUR SONGS.
LOOK, JON, IN FRANCE, 1.6
MILLION PEOPLE MARCHED FOR 12
CARTOONISTS, WHICH IS GREAT.
BUT BY THAT MATH, THE WHOLE
WORLD SHOULD HAVE BEEN MARCHING
IN NIGERIA.
LIKE SOMETIMES IT JUST FEELS
LIKE AFRICA IS THE VEGAS OF
ISLAMIC TERROR -- WHAT HAPPENS
IN AFRICA STAYS IN AFRICA.
>> Jon: THAT WAS A
TREMENDOUS ACCENT.
( LAUGHTER )
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jon: WELL, YOU KNOW,
DOESN'T IT STAY IN AFRICA?
I MEAN, DOES IT REALLY AFFECT US
HERE? I MEAN --
>> WELL, YOU'D THINK THAT, JON.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE UNDERWEAR
BOMBER?
HE WAS NIGERIAN.
>> Jon: OH, RIGHT.
AND BECAUSE OF HIM, YOU KNOW,
NOBODY IS ALLOWED TO WEAR
UNDERWEAR ON AIRPLANES NOW.
>> I-- I THINK YOU ARE.
>> Jon: BETTER SAFE THAN
SORRY IS WHAT I WOULD SAY.
THE POINT IS THIS, "CHARLIE
HEBDO" WAS A DIRECT ATTACK ON
OUR WESTERN VALUES OF FREE
SPEECH AND EXPRESSION.
>> RIGHT.
AND BOKO HARAM LITERALLY MEANS
WESTERN EDUCATION IS FORBIDDEN.
>> Jon: REALLY?
>> YOU SEE, JON, WE'RE FIGHTING
THE SAME TERRORISM, SO NEXT
TIME, JUST INCLUDE US IN YOUR
MARCHES.
NIGERIAN SCHOOL GIRLS USE
PENCILS, TOO, SO YOU DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO CHANGE THE PROPS.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, WE'D LOVE
TO, TREVOR, HONESTLY, THE STATES
WOULD LOVE TO, BUT OUR GLOBAL
WAR ON TERROR CALENDAR IS SO
FULL BETWEEN THE ISIS, THEY'RE
TRYING TO SET UP A CALIPHATE
AND --
>> YEAH, AND SO IS BOKO HARAM.
THEY KIDNAP PEOPLE, THEY SELL
THEM INTO SLAVERY.
>> Jon: THAT'S PRETTY ISIS-ISH.
>> YEAH. THEY WEAR THESE
COSTUMES.
>> Jon: HOLY ( BLEEP ).
THAT'S ISIS-ISH.
THAT'S LIKE ISIS COUTURE.
>> YEAH. ARAB SPRING COLLECTION,
IN FACT.
>> Jon: NICE.
>> THEY EVEN HAVE THE SAME FLAG,
JON.
>> Jon: THEY HAVE THE SAME FLAG?
THAT'S JUST LAZY.
>> DON'T YOU SEE, JON, BOKO
HARAM IS BLACK ISIS.
>> Jon: THAT SOUNDS LIKE
THE MOST AWESOME PAM GRIER MOVIE
EVER.
( LAUGHTER )
>> YOU KNOW, JON, BOKO HARAM
MUST FEEL LIKE TYLER PERRY--
HUGE NUMBERS BUT NO RECOGNITION.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: LOOK, TREVOR, I GET
IT, BUT WE'RE SO BUSY FIGHTING--
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S TOO BAD BECAUSE IF BOKO
HARAM IS NOT STOPPED THEY MIGHT
TAKE OVER NIGERIA'S OIL FIELDS?
AND --
>> Jon: EH, EH, EH -- NIGERIA'S
WHAT NOW?
>> WELL, OIL.
NIGERIA HAS THE WORLD'S TENTH
BIGGEST OIL RESERVES,
37 BILLION BARRELS.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Jon: IT'S FUNNY.
ACTUALLY AS I THINK ABOUT
IT WE DO HAVE AN OPENING
RIGHT AFTER-- I THINK-- IN
BETWEEN ISIS AND YEMEN,
I THINK WE CAN SQUEEZE YOU IN.
PERHAPS WE CAN HAVE JAMES TAYLOR
OVER THERE RIGHT AWAY.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS CALL AND
♪ HE'LL BE THERE, YES, HE WILL ♪
YOU'VE GOT A FRIEND ♪♪
>> JE SUIS TOO YOUNG TO KNOW
THAT SONG, BUT THANK YOU.
>> Jon: THANK YOU, TREVOR.
TREVOR NOAH, EVERYBODY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )